Ellington fighting not interested in UFC
just since I was 18 I had my first fight
30.
how many fights you have as a pro 31
that's so but you see people don't know
I I my team always busts my balls for
this because I always say well I have
this was my 40th fight I've only had two
amateur fights I just but I've really
had nine amateur fights but only two
were actually like what I would say
amateur rules with puffy gloves and oh
yeah seven other ones I had were in
Arkansas and Mississippi and Louisiana
where that's just when you show up to
fighter meeting and you wearing four
ounce gloves and they say who hands up
if you guys want to throw elbows uh okay
so now we're throwing elbows like I
fought Pro fights I just didn't get paid
for it 45 I have 38 fights two amateur